nos braconniers se confondent très
souvent avec les autres chasseurs en
donnant l'impression de respecter les
règles mais une technique courante
consiste à utiliser en échange d'un peu
de viande dit permis de chasse d'autres
personnes de leur entourage afin de tuer
beaucoup plus de bêtes que la limite
autorisée par un seul permis
les braconniers sont aussi équipés des
différents appareils maintenant de
communication pour éviter de se faire
prendre
au québec les agents de protection de la
faune demande ainsi fréquemment aux
citoyens aux chasseurs aux autres
chasseurs dans la forêt de ne pas
hésiter à utiliser le service
téléphonique sos braconnage
s'ils sont témoins d'infraction ou de
comportement louche car seuls ne
suffisent pas à la tâche
dans la seule région par exemple du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean ils sont moins
de 30 pour les milliers de chasseurs est
l'un de ces agents de protection de la
faune au québec des choses qui ont été
finalement se sont donc faites donc
c'est certain comme toutes les jeunes
remarques des choses signal était fait
enquête en suivant un thème qui on peut
dire aussi que la population de vienne
ont lieu à quelque part et nous met au
courant le d
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
le grand territoire qui est vaste mais
le monde et pipi à tout finit toujours
par se savoir prédire donc à ce niveau
là lorsque vous rassurer que tous les
signalements sont couverts de problème
il ya 25 ans aucune statistique fiable
nationale n'existait ni les incidents
rapportés par les agents de conservation
da ponte
au niveau des différentes provinces se
multipliaient et il était à ce point
fréquent qu'à cette époque le canada a
commencé à se doter de lois de
véritables lois possédant des dans un
extrait entendu à l'arrêt
d'état le canada dispose depuis quelques
jours à peine d'une nouvelle loi sur le
braconnage
geneviève rossier s'est intéressé à la
question la nouvelle loi facilitera la
lutte au trafic de ces espèces
l'ancienne loi ne visait que le gibier
et l'animal devait être mort et gare à
ceux qui ne respectent pas la loi
la mode pour les individus sera de 150
mille dollars
elle double à la deuxième infraction et
en cas d'infraction grave
les braconniers pourrait se retrouver en
prison pour cinq ans clôt de francisco
avait aujourd'hui la ville comme 85 %
des canadiens mais à cette époque il y
avait 25 ans à leurs enfants
il résidait à la campagne où son père
louer un chalet en pleine forêt à des
touristes étrangers
petite cabane en pointu avec des
branches qui a peut-être qu'à pieds de
profond par m 2 deux pieds de large
on essaie de trouver des jardins
bourolleau que cette configuration là on
bouge du côté on nous met des branches
la plage en ouverture à peu près de 2 2
qui en deux ans les autres ont fait
c'est qu'on comprend un arbre plus gros
et on le met à la coller sur les autres
avant juste en arrière à l'époque on
était un piège à tard m maintenant on a
tous droit de faire son mea d'époque on
prenne fin on mettait des pièges à
takeda aux cerqueux et aux fondus de la
cabane on mettait des poissons mettait
de la chambre en quelque chose pour
espérer des autres dont klaus lui qui se
faisait pour aller manger ils devaient
enjamber la bouche puis se prenaient la
part d'un siège pour laquelle j'étais
plutôt content et de la bouche d'une
requête en beau mélo cage lui il est
attaché après 7,2 sont donc une fois que
l'ours était prise il s'en allait avec
la bouche mais la bio shadow 15 ou 20
pieds de large de l'eau peut-être
suppose de diamètre dont klaus à des
palois moins huit rien et que ça comme
un boulet ouais c'est ça donc qu'un
qatar il est battu pour out vous faire
suivre la draft il avait labouré le
chemin pendant
au moins
qualifié de l'argent des bijoux trouvés
ils avaient la pâte déchiqueté déchirure
la pâte
qu'est ce que vous faisiez lorsque
l'animal il bien sûr il était encore en
vie vous preniez votre carradine et vous
deux méthodes soit exprès car adn même
ça ça lui c'est bien au mieux du point
mais face à lui le dessus de sa tête sur
le début qu'on on allait là pour
récupérer la peau bien on utilisait le
to qui était fait pour forcer le couteau
donc la peau était pas dommage et parce
qu'on disait le tout tient il ya une
autre façon aussi c'était le squash
devrait-elle 0 tc pareilles ma quand on
prenait l'ancrant si on faisait deux
looks à chaque bout l'on prenait une
perche qui est assez longue
j'étais a toujours un homme qui avait
une cagade bien d'autres pierrine
externe et donc ont requis chaque fois
ce soit aux autres études pour une
protégée
après l'inde géant branche du huffington
post est d'accord dans le cloud de
l'ours dont on faisait deux fois l'or
reprenait les des deux cartes qui
étaient d'accord avec lui c'est la main
à son fils de la ville mais chaque bout
d'accord il y avait deux personnes
tirées chaque côté de l'eau dont c'était
étrange il ne devrait pas être debout
quand même non c'est ce que met toutes
les deux façons qu'on faisait à l'époque
j'avais juste à l'est j'allais avec des
jets qui étaient des salaires et
pourquoi ils utilisaient pas plutôt la
carabine
enfin de bruit parce que c'était pas
tout à fait légale c'est ça un reportage
de radio canada international